Traductor: Jenny Lam-Chowdhury
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
En la década de 1920,
el matemático alemán David Hilbert
creó un famoso ejercicio mental
para mostrarnos lo difícil que es
entender el concepto de infinito.
Imaginen un hotel con una cantidad
infinita de habitaciones
y un gerente nocturno muy eficiente.
Una noche, el Hotel Infinito
está completamente lleno,
totalmente ocupado con una
cantidad infinita de huéspedes.
Un hombre llega al hotel
y pide una habitación.
En vez de despacharlo,
el gerente nocturno decide
conseguirle una habitación.
¿Cómo?
Fácil... le pide al huésped
de la habitación núm. 1
que se pase a la habitación núm. 2,
al huésped de la habitación núm. 2
a la habitación núm. 3,
y así sucesivamente.
Todos los huéspedes se mueven
de la habitación número "n"
a la habitación número "n+1".
Como hay una cantidad infinita
de habitaciones,
hay una habitación
para cada huésped.
Esto deja la habitación núm. 1
vacía para el nuevo huésped.
El proceso puede repetirse
para cualquier número infinito
de nuevos huéspedes.
Si, digamos, llega un autobús
con 40 nuevos huéspedes
en busca de habitaciones,
entonces todos los huéspedes
alojados se pasan
de la habitación número "n"
a la habitación número "n+40",
vaciando así las 40
primeras habitaciones.
Pero ahora un autobús
infinitamente largo
con un infinito numerable de pasajeros
llega para alquilar cuartos.
Infinito numerable es la clave.
Ahora, el bus infinito con
cantidad de pasajeros infinita
deja inicialmente atónito
al gerente nocturno,
pero este se da cuenta
de que hay una forma
de darle hospedaje a todos.
Le pide al huésped
de la habitación núm. 1
que se pase a la habitación núm. 2.
Luego le pide al huésped
de la habitación núm. 2
que se pase a la habitación núm. 4,
al huésped de la habitación 3
que se pase a la habitación 6,
y así sucesivamente.
Todos los huéspedes se pasan
de la habitación número "n"
a la habitación número "2n",
llenando únicamente las habitaciones
con número infinitos pares.
Al hacer esto, se han vaciado
todas las habitaciones con
números infinitos impares,
que son ocupados por las personas
que venían en el bus infinito.
Todo el mundo está feliz
y el negocio del hotel
prospera más que nunca.
Bueno, de hecho está prosperando
exactamente de la misma
forma que siempre,
cobrando una suma infinita
de dólares por noche.
Se corre la voz sobre
este hotel increíble.
Viene gente de todas partes.
Una noche ocurre lo más inesperado.
El gerente nocturno mira hacia afuera
y ve una cola infinita
de buses infinitamente largos,
todos con una cantidad
numerable infinita de pasajeros.
¿Qué puede hacer?
Si no puede conseguirles habitaciones
el hotel perderá
una cantidad infinita de dinero,
y él ciertamente perderá el trabajo.
Con suerte se acuerda
que alrededor del año 300 a.C.
Euclides demostró que hay
una cantidad infinita
de números primos.
Así que para lograr lo que
parece una tarea imposible
de conseguir camas infinitas
para los buses infinitos
con una cantidad infinita
de viajeros cansados,
el gerente nocturno le asigna
a todos los huéspedes existentes
el primer número primo, 2,
elevado al número de la habitación
en la que están hospedados.
Así que el huésped de la habitación 7
se pasa a la habitación 2^7,
que es la habitación 128.
El gerente nocturno
toma a todas las personas
en el primero de los buses infinitos
y le asigna las habitaciones
del próximo número primo, 3,
elevado al número correspondiente
a sus asientos en el bus.
Así que la persona
del asiento 7 del primer bus,
se hospedará en la habitación 3^7
o la habitación 2187.
Así continúa para todos
en el primer bus.
A los pasajeros del segundo bus
se les asignan según los exponentes
de 5, el próximo número primo.
El siguiente bus,
según los exponentes de 7.
Así continúa con los buses que siguen:
según los exponentes de 11,
los exponentes de 13,
los exponentes de 17, etc.
Como cada uno de estos números
solo tienen el 1 y números naturales
como exponentes de estos números primos
que funcionan como base,
no hay una superposición en los números.
A todos los pasajeros de los buses
se les asigna una habitación
empleando un sistema
de asignación único,
basados en números primos únicos.
De esta forma,
el gerente nocturno puede alojar
a todos los pasajeros
en todos los buses.
Sin embargo, habrá habitaciones
que quedarán vacías,
como la habitación 6,
porque el 6 no es la potencia
de ningún número primo.
Con suerte sus jefes no eran
muy buenos en matemáticas,
así que su trabajo está asegurado.
Las estrategias del gerente nocturno
son solo posibles
porque aunque el Hotel Infinito
es ciertamente una pesadilla logística,
solo tiene que lidiar
con números infinitos bajos,
principalmente, los infinitos contables
de los números naturales,
como 1, 2, 3, 4 y así por el estilo.
Georg Cantor denominó este nivel
de infinito álef-cero.
Usamos número naturales
en las habitaciones,
así como en los
asientos de los buses.
Si tuviésemos que lidiar con
niveles de infinito más altos,
como el de los números reales,
estas estrategias estructuradas
no serían posible
porque no hay manera
de que podamos incluir sistemáticamente
todos los números.
El Hotel Infinito de los
Números Reales tendría
habitaciones con números
negativos en el sótano,
habitaciones con fracciones,
de modo que el huésped de la
habitación 1/2 siempre sospechará
que tiene menos espacio que el huésped
en la habitación número 1.
Habitaciones a la raíz cuadrada,
como la habitación radical de 2,
la habitación pi,
donde los huéspedes esperan
recibir postres gratis.
¿Qué gerente nocturno que se respete
querría trabajar allí
así sea por un salario infinito?
Pero en el Hotel Infinito de Hilbert,
donde nunca hay una vacante,
y siempre hay más cuartos,
los escenarios que enfrenta
el siempre muy diligente
y quizás demasiado hospitalario
gerente nocturno
nos sirve para recordarnos
lo difícil que es
para nuestras mentes
relativamente finitas
entender un concepto tan grande
como el infinito.
Quizás puedan ayudar a abordar
estos problemas
después de una buena
noche de descanso.
Aunque honestamente,
quizás tengamos
que cambiarlos de habitación
a las 2 de la mañana.